- Good morning.
(audience applauding)
Wow. Clapping, I love it.
Can you guys all hear me out there?
It sounds like it.
I almost forgot I had a clicker
put in my pocket on accident.
So yeah, excited to be here
today and talk about GenAI.
Just a little bit about me.
I've been in this industry
for over 20 years.
I guess I aged myself a little bit,
back when we used to
have other words, right?
We used to talk about NLP
more and now it's all GenAI,
and everyone might remember
image registration versus computer vision
and all those good things.
So I've been working on this a long time
and helping companies develop that.
And working with AWS,
we've won a lot of awards
and been runners up in GenAI consulting
for the last two years
in AI and other years.
So Mission is really
here to help you guys.
We built out over 175 projects
over the last two years.
We're the first SI partner
to get access to Bedrock.
So we've been building on
Bedrock for 2 1/2 years.
So if you guys have questions,
feel free to come and find us,
our booth is right behind
this in the dev center,
right behind it.
So excited to talk to you guys
and see, you know, whether we can continue
the conversation we have today.
How many of you guys saw this article?
How many of you guys actually
read any of these articles?
Oh, actually way better than usual.
It's, you know, I love headlines nowadays.
It's all a lot of click bait, right?
Trying to get people
to come in and read it.
But what did the article actually say?
It did say yes, 95% did
not see measurable ROI.
But what does measurable ROI mean, right?
It doesn't mean they didn't see ROI,
they just didn't see something
that they felt really
had a big return, right?
2x, 3x, or things like that.
It might've only had like a 1.1x return,
but they still, 40% of them
did put this into deployment,
and so it still, even though
that article said only 5%,
you still saw 40% put into deployment.
And the number I really
like is that 67% of those
were done by companies like Mission
that were able to come in
and help companies build
because we have that
expertise to help you.
And the other thing it said,
one of the issues people always had
was they chose bad use cases, right?
That is the one thing you
should always be looking at
is what use case am I doing, right?
AI isn't the problem most of the time,
AI does what you tell it,
but you are choosing a
bad problem to solve.
You are looking at maybe
something that was,
I'm gonna build images
in my marketing team
or something like that,
and then you're having a
hard time quantifying it,
'cause hey, I'm only saving
a little bit of money by doing that.
And so you're not seeing that massive ROI.
Now, people that were
looking at better use cases
that were automating, you
know, run of the mill tasks
that weren't that interesting,
were able to see a lot more ROI.
Also, you know, a lot
of internal experts are,
you know, important to have.
You need it, but it's
not insufficient, right?
You need to also be working with people
that understand the tech.
and then I'm sure you guys
have seen it over and over,
especially as you look at coding tools,
that this is not just a technology change,
it's a cultural change, right?
How many of you guys have
started to look at like Kiro
as a developing platform?
A couple of people.
And so Kiro is really pushing
on spec-driven coding, right?
Most of the time when
you're looking at coding,
people just kind of start
and they start making their application,
and they don't really think
out all the little steps.
But now as you start
using these coding agents,
you have to start thinking about
what are each of the steps?
I need to start looking
at it really early.
And so now your developers
need to start thinking
more like product managers, right?
So you're gonna see this
real cultural change
that has to happen inside these systems.
So it's really important
that people understand that.
So little bit of a summary,
we're gonna talk about who we are.
Kind of mentioned it already.
We do a lot of AWS stuff,
tons of competencies in
all the different spaces.
And so we are a one stop shop
where we do cost ops and
resell, 24/7 support,
and then professional services.
So if you're looking for any of those,
feel free to come and talk to us.
And now I like to just talk
a little bit about GenAI.
Who thinks GenAI's new?
And obviously you can see my slide
and know that I don't
think it's new, right?
It really dates back to 1906.
Who thought it went back
over a hundred years?
Anybody?
Nobody thought it went back.
So that was probabilistic
text generation in 1906.
Think about that.
These are like handwritten algorithms
to figure out what text should
come next in a sentence.
Then you kinda had a lot of
early concepts in the 50s.
There were a lot of rule-based systems.
You started to see early neural nets.
But then we had the AI winner, right?
And then the 80s came,
and now everyone had personal computers
and you started to see
clusters in universities.
So neural nets were pushed
further and further again, right?
And then the early 2010s,
this is when the research on GaN started.
And a lot of it was really enabled
because now I have the cloud, right?
That's kind of when the cloud started,
now I have infinite compute
and storage essentially, right?
And so that's really where you started
to see all of these things.
And then, you know, in the 2020s,
did anyone use GPT-1 or GPT-2 past myself?
A couple of guys maybe. Yeah.
So like in the early 2020s
we were doing GPT-1 stuff
and then '22, GPT-2,
there were things done,
and now everything is agents.
Who looked at my pretty chart, right?
I love using image generation. It's great.
Does the timeline really work?
Did anyone notice that great timeline?
So I then prompt it better.
I'm like, "I can prompt better."
And I made it worse.
How many of us love prompting?
Anybody love prompting?
But I really like a good timeline
that has the 1500s
mixed in with the 1900s.
It's a really powerful tool here.
So I like to ask this question.
What innovation happened in 2023
that made everyone excited about GenAI?
Anyone, shout it out.
ChatGPT. What was ChatGPT?
Anybody?
Okay, ChatGPT was someone made a website.
That's it, right?
These models existed,
they just were more accessed
by people like myself
that's a data scientist that
would spin it up in SageMaker,
you know, maybe you're using
Hugging Face at the time,
but now you have a website
that fronts a model
that you can now talk to.
They made it intuitive,
right? It's cool, it works.
And so, but that's the innovation
when you really think about it
is someone just made it
easier to access a model.
That's it, that's the whole
craze that started is,
it's now easy for anyone
to think about it,
look at the ideas and understand
where you can go from there.
So for us, we have our own chat bot.
Everyone probably has
a chat bot now, right?
You can make them super easy.
Bedrock even has OpenSearch
and you can create a chat bot,
and you're gonna ask all
kinds of of fun questions
to your chat bot.
Like, I got a a little joke
going on with my own chat bot.
But why is it a chat bot?
It's really because that's the easiest way
to do back and forth conversations, right?
And you're really looking at
how do I simplify the interactions?
'Cause everyone is looking at
I just wanna be able to talk
to it and get information out.
Now, what we've noticed is that people now
just confuse everything
with a chat bot, right?
Because they wanna talk to things.
They may want to have
traditional ML models.
You still may wanna do clustering,
or you wanna do some kind
of prescriptive analytics
or things like that.
But all that people wanna say is like,
"I just wanna talk to my
data, or I wanna do this."
And so everything gets
buried behind a chat bot.
So even though someone's coming to you
and they may be asking about GenAI,
often it's just an interface, right?
So to think about that,
your chatbots, often just your
interface and now chatbots,
you're gonna have kickstart,
you know, agentic workflows.
And then the other thing we
see a lot of is just gen BI.
How many of you guys have
used like QuickSight Q
or Quick Suite, or any of those tools?
Couple of people.
So, you know, they're really nice,
but like you said, they
do have limitations.
And so people are using generative systems
with cool React libraries
to come and populate all of your graphs,
and then you really get into
pushing an LLM to write code.
So there's a lot of
really fun things there,
but at the end of the day,
everyone is looking at
how can I just talk to the system?
So that's why chatbots have
become our main interface.
So (indistinct) for a minute.
I like images, as you guys can see, right?
The good.
I asked for an monkey astronaut
riding the bike on the moon.
How did we do? We do good?
Well, it did mostly good.
There is a moon in the background
if anyone didn't catch that bit.
And early on, it was really
bad at letters, right?
So it actually works pretty
well with letters and all that.
And then we get into the bad.
Anybody have a guess on what
I wanted the system to do?
Any guesses?
- [Audience Member] Tower Bridge?
- Tower Bridge. Good guess, good guess.
But I asked for an AWS
architecture diagram
of Glue connected to Redshift
connected to QuickSight.
How did we do? Anybody?
Did we do good? Did we do bad?
This woman is very smart, she
says we did good, and we did.
I asked for things for
an architecture diagram,
it's buildings, we made architecture,
I said Glue, glued them together.
How many people know what Redshift is?
Sunset, right? Sunset.
So it made a sunset.
It did exactly what I asked it to do.
It just didn't really
understand that I needed
to have a diagram that
had boxes of SageMaker
and things like that attached to it,
but it did exactly what I wanted.
And so that's one of the
bad parts about GenAI
is it will always give you an answer.
It's not necessarily the
answer you want or you need,
but it will give you an answer.
And so you as the individual
have to be looking at the answers,
and you have to come and
understand what am I trying to do?
Now the ugly.
We were doing an event in July,
and we wanted Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
Now, these are some older GenAI images,
but I use them for an example
because the new ones will create
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer,
but before, they wouldn't.
And we went through a lot
of prompted iterations,
there were like 30 pictures in the series,
so I'll only show a few.
And, you know, I was
like, give me a reindeer
with a red nose, and nothing.
Then I was like trying to go closer,
and it was like, give me a
reindeer with a clown nose,
and it gave me a balloon
with a clown balloon.
So it just, it didn't really get it right.
Now, I was giving this talk a
while back and someone goes,
"Do you know what the biggest
problem is with your images?"
And I said, "No."
I'm sitting there thinking,
"Hey, I'm gonna win
because it's not Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer," right?
And so this guy's like, "Do
you know the real issue?"
And I don't know how
many of you guys know,
but this is a whitetail buck deer.
It's not even a reindeer.
So if you're asking questions to GenAI
and you don't really know the answer
or what you're expecting,
you can't even validate
that it's giving you the right answer,
because to me I was like,
"Oh yeah, that looks like a reindeer.
It just doesn't look like Rudolph."
So it's really important as
you're building these systems
that you can understand,
how do I validate it?
How do I prove out that it is
giving me the answers I want?
How am I going to write unit tests?
How am I gonna make
cases that just validate
that yes, the answer's coming out?
Especially when you're gonna
deliver a system to people
that may not know what
the answer should be,
because it will hallucinate.
How many of you guys get inundated
with all the news, right?
Even last week was crazy, right,
there were like 10 new announcements,
everything's giving you whiplash.
The advice we often give
to people is choose a model
that works for your particular use case,
and each use case may have
a slightly different model
that you're using, but choose one family,
and then you just keep using that family
because you're gonna gain expertise.
They're all like coding languages, right?
You don't want your coders to be switching
from Python to .NET to everything
because they're just not gonna be as adept
at getting the answers
as if they just always are
working in the same family.
And every model's always like
leapfrogging the next, right?
So wait two weeks and whatever
your favorite model is
is gonna be the top model
on the leaderboards.
So you don't have to always
do that model hopping.
The other thing that's always
kind of interesting to me
is did you guys read any of the reports
when OpenAI launched GPT-5?
Anybody read the reports?
So OpenAI said that GPT-5 hallucinates
40% to 45% of the time.
Anybody know that? Huge, right?
Hallucinations are
astronomical in these systems.
Now, if you connect GPT-5 to the internet,
which is why OpenAI has GPT-5
connected to the internet,
the hallucination rate drops to 6%.
And so that's why if you're
building a model inside of AWS,
you need to be either
attaching it to the internet
or putting it with a RAG database
so that you can push your
hallucinations down, right?
If you're not doing that,
you will be looking at the probability
of a high hallucination rate
depending on the questions you're asking.
So it's really important
to think about that
when you're building out these systems.
GenAI agents.
Is everyone tired of GenAI agents? No?
Wow, I'm tired of GenAI agents.
So agents are fun, right?
It's gonna go do everything.
I've got an agent there,
he's my group leader,
he's got all my other sub-agents,
I'm gonna send them out,
I'm gonna do all kinds of cool things.
We're gonna have some
autonomous goal achievement
and we're gonna decide
how to answer all of our questions, right?
Now, when you look at
agents, it's really important
to understand your use case,
because I feel especially, you know,
most engineers I talk to
have just gotten lazy.
They're like drawing a diagram
that's just like agent to do this,
an agent to do that, an
agent to do this, right?
They're not even really
putting in the thought,
like what does each of those agents do?
Is it actually an agent or is it a prompt?
On my team, there's a lot of people
and we have conversations all the time,
is that a prompt or is it an agent?
And there's a lot of things
between the two of those, right?
Like if I go to an agent, I
have to build the framework,
although there's AgentCore, right, now
to do the framework to make it easier.
But you still have, when
you're doing agents,
delays in your time.
So if you have time-critical matters,
often you're going to wanna just run
with prompts versus agents
because you're gonna get
the answer back faster
through just a prompt.
And most of the time you can prompt
most of the things you're trying
to do that an agent can do.
And so that's things to look
at, is what's my use case?
Do I really need an agent?
Agents are also potentially
gonna be more expensive,
and they take longer.
So you really have to think
about what's my system?
Am I really doing something
that's an agent or not an agent?
So we've done a lot of
use cases, as I mentioned,
tons and tons of cool stuff.
I won't get to talk
about too many of these,
but we've done everything.
I haven't seen anything
new in at least six months,
so if you guys have use
cases, wanna ask about,
hey, would this be possible?
Can we do that or not?
We're here, like I said,
back over that way,
right on this side of
the CrowdStrike booth.
The biggest use cases we
see in the market right now
are IDP, right?
About 60% of the market's doing IDP stuff.
Really cool space.
Then you've got chatbots, as
I mentioned, doing chatbots,
but then there's everything else, right?
Code generation,
recruiting, drug discovery,
there's cool things you
can do with chatbots
where you can do training,
educational training,
or other training of your employees.
And if they're going the wrong route,
you can iteratively change
how the chatbot responds.
So we had that built in where
we were working with a company
that does medical
training for new doctors,
and if the doctor was
going down a wrong path
of questioning, the agent
would then get agitated.
Well, the patient would then get agitated
and start being like, "Hey,
you've asked me that already."
And stuff like that, right?
So there's really cool things you can do.
Dubbing and translation's been
big, all kinds of cool stuff.
And then like I mentioned,
chatbots is that interface.
If you really want to learn about chatbots
or have us build you a chatbot,
we have a lot of really cool
fast track packages out there
that we can help you guys build these.
These are things we've
done day in and day out.
They're really cool.
Quick Suite, QuickSight, you know,
that's something you guys
will see a lot of this week.
Something to look at and talk about.
So I'll just skip
through IDP for a second.
So this was a really fun use case for IDP.
We were working with an insurance company,
and they're underwriters,
so they get applications all the time.
And the underwriters
spending four to five hours
on the system.
And so this company, it gets
10 to 15,000 applications,
and they were growing,
they just got bought by a
bigger insurance company,
and so they can't hire fast enough, right?
So that's one of those use
cases where you look at
how much just manual work is there,
how are you going to solve that problem?
And if it's most of the time
I hire and train somebody,
then you can probably automate it, right?
So that's the system to look
at, I'm gonna automate this.
And then you can build
out IDP really cool.
And then you can put
everything into a database,
and you can ask questions to it, right?
So now the underwriter will get results,
and then if he asks questions
where he wants a further answer,
he can then ask about the
application to do his work.
And so it was really neat, we
were able to take their time
from, you know, four to five
hours down to two hours,
saving them 50%.
And so there's massive things.
This was just the first phase, right?
We're looking at how can we
help continue to improve this
to get it down even further?
So there are tons of savings out there
when you look at these chat bots.
So another, retrieval
augmented generation,
I'm sure everyone knows
retrieval augmented generation.
Here's a pretty standard
architecture, right?
Some kind of interface connected
to an LLM connected to,
you know, your agents at the
end of the day and all that.
And so we were working with a company,
and this is where we get into all of that,
like timing bits, right?
So this is the IVR system.
So now you have to think
about somebody's on the phone,
they're calling and they're talking
to a, you know, your bot.
And so it has to be fast.
So I don't know if you
guys have used Nova,
but Nova Micro is actually pretty awesome
where you can sort through really quickly
with Nova Micro on the inference
side, get to an answer,
and see what's going on there.
And this was kind of the architecture
for kind of an IVR system.
Has Connect, which we all love Connect,
Lex, Polly, to do the text to voice.
So a lot of really cool things going on.
Now, I have way too many slides,
but we do lots of cool stuff.
We could have talked about
agents and cool things.
So on agents, I'm giving a talk
with AWS in like two weeks about agents.
So, you know, anyone that was here,
just look for a talk about agents.
It's a pretty cool use case.
Lots of fun architecture at the end.
AgentCore, and I have way
too many slides, sorry.
But if you wanna work together,
you can find us in the booth in the back.
I put out a newsletter every week.
I think we talk about fun, cool stuff.
So if anyone wants to
hear my random thoughts,
this is how you can hear it.
Appreciate you guys all attending today.
And they're gonna give me
the hook in 19 seconds.
So if anyone has a question,
you know, like I said,
I'll be over at our booth
for the next 30 ish minutes
and happy to talk through
anything you guys want.
But thank you, everyone.
(audience applauding)